hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here with some
more jiu jitsu madness for what i am
told is the long-awaited
shibby arc which would appear to be a
gigantic chaotic climax of the series to
this point and we're going to go through
about half of it in this video because i
got to the point where the chapters
started to have just insane titles like
the shibuya incident
part 27 and with no end in sight i just
i just sort of needed to call it there
and that's because this arc really does
confront you with an overwhelming amount
of content and to have a chance of
properly dissecting it i need to dump a
load of thoughts right here
right now and before i do just a quick
reminder that if you are an anime only
watcher and you've
somehow stumbled upon this video big big
spoilers are coming your way so continue
at your own peril and speaking of peril
without a certain gojo in the picture
your only hope of surviving this video
is to activate the subscribe button for
the new world of view thus granting
regular injections of judekis and
morbidity administered straight into
your youtube feed i really don't like
your chances of survival without having
pressed that button so
let's just get on to it yeah but the
premise of shibuya thus far goes as
follows mahito and ko
perhaps better referred to as mahiko
have enacted their grand scale plan to
seal gojo rather successfully and are
proceeding to course havoc
in shibuya ideally is phase one to rid
the world of humanity and it's up to
everyone who is
not gojo to stop them sounds quite
simple but
it isn't there's a lot of insanity being
explored here from character
interactions to advanced cursed combat
and even the profound philosophical
struggle of body and soul shibaya seems
to come equipped with you know a little
bit of everything even mecca style
warfare as we begin this arc with a
three chapter battle between mahito and
mekamaru who has apparently constructed
his own evangelion unit which i point
out specifically because this ultimate
makamaru takes clear visual and even
functional inspiration from that
franchise specifically not all
surprising because akatami is a big fan
of just sort of injecting pop culture
everywhere he can but this was
quite a way to begin and the expanded
nature of this singular fight
really did set up the idea that we were
in for quite a long hallock previously
jiu-jitsu kaisen has not really had a
ton of specific fights that span
multiple chapters solely focusing on
them at least ones that weren't art
climaxes so this really did let me know
that yeah we were going to take our time
here and these three chapters also did a
very good job of endearing me to
makamaru before
unceremoniously removing him from this
world or i guess at least most of him
it was quite touching to see his drive
to just to live with everyone and from a
narrative standpoint what this fight
accomplished was the beginning
of the exploration of domains so wow
her domain shibuya thus far has been
more or less a master class of domain
combat and functionality what the
mechamara aspect did specifically was
expanding upon a previously installed
idea of the simple domain and how it can
even be used to counter a full domain
and that idea then went on to be
extensively used by characters like
mehme's brother and even now betosenin
although his technique was was
technically different to a simple domain
but it was
the same general effect but even with
full domains a massive aspect of gojo's
battle in the sark was domain
mind games the whole idea that jogo
cannot use his domain because that would
force gojo to counter with his
domain and this whole incident is just
one big battle of pure tactics which i
love because these parts of a shonen
sirius can sometimes drag out
quite a bit with fairly boring
mechanisms of battle that just consist
of
summoning more power and like punching
things but shibuya is actually quite
complex and i'd be lying if i said i had
a complete handle on everything that was
happening at this stage in fact this is
an arc where akhitami has even had to
start making these fun little mini maps
to keep us up to date with locations
characters and even cursed mechanics
like the whole idea that there were four
curtains thrown up around the area
simultaneously each with different
purposes
it really is not as simple as some sort
of big world-ending thread there is an
absolute ass ton of technicalities at
play which make me feel like these
antagonists have really put some effort
into this plan
instead of doing something more
narratively lazy like gathering the
like of the magic rocks and then
summoning a big power thing you know how
it always goes but with that let's move
to gojo as i think i've said before his
very existence is a problem not just to
our antagonist but also to akhitami
because for
anything interesting or dramatic to ever
play out in jiu-jitsu kaisen gojo either
needs to be absent or disabled because
that's the risk of making a character
with his
frankly absurd level of power having
said that the way in which he was taken
out of the picture here was quite
brilliant it's not only clever but
satisfying and also gave gojo a lot of
cool moments to act before ultimately
being sealed in the prison realm
and of course it was also far from easy
even resulting in the death of hanami
which was surprisingly sad however my
favorite moment of this gojo-centric
conflict was this two-page spread
because you know what we almost
never see in the entirety of the manga
medium curved panels
curves and circles are pretty commonly
seen in western comics but these two
pages kind of stunned me because i'm
really not used to seeing any kind of
curve to lay out in manga and i suppose
one reason for that is because it does
make the pages and atmosphere a lot more
passive whereas jagged and straight
lines are much more action-packed and
exciting but even so i love what akutami
does here because these curves form sort
of like a visual sync with gojo in the
middle and all of the focus is flowing
down straight towards him like water
down a drain i won't linger on it too
long even though i do really like these
pages but what i also enjoyed was the
gojo conflict instilled a very harsh
sense of reality with gojo accepting
that he would not be able to save
everyone but promising vengeance in
return
even accepting the damage that his own
domain expansion would cause
and actually having said that here's a
thing random tangent here but
what is going on with the english
translation of jujutsukaisen in this arc
gojo's domain is called an immeasurable
void but it was
absolutely 100 called unlimited void the
first time he used it way back in like
chapter 15.
also fujiguro's shadow garden is now
called a domain expansion instead of an
area expansion and i i honestly don't
care
what they decide to go with but would it
be possible to maybe
just maybe stay consistent with stuff
like this because using different
terminology for the exact same mechanic
makes me think that they're different
mechanics like when i first saw a
measurable void i thought it was oh it
was a different brand of domain to
unlimited void so basically get your
crap together there is really no excuse
for mistranslating something that you've
already established way way way way back
in the series already and like i'd
understand if there was a difference
between the anime and the manga in fact
i think there is or like official versus
fan
translations but when it comes to the
fact there are differences in just this
one official product itself it's kind of
annoying anyway moving on we also have
an answer to a question that i brought
up reviewing the prequel and it turns
out that gojo did
kill ghetto good boy gojo i never should
have doubted you and i am really glad to
know this reading the prequel with
ghetto survival in mind was kind of
off-putting but this
is not in fact ghetto or is it i don't
know
there's questions so many questions one
of which is one of the craziest
questions that is currently being
explored which is challenging mahito's
philosophy of the soul
shaping the body we've now had a series
of examples during this variance where
the body itself seems to fight the soul
for control this happened with ghetto's
body but also with toji's body and toji
well by the way we will get to you but
this is a pretty fascinating and bizarre
discussion that i frankly was not
expecting to have because if you do
believe in the concept of a soul then
it's such an accepted idea that goes
along with that that the body is nothing
but a shell for said soul but jujutsukai
sin is challenging that pretty radically
by positing that the body and the soul
may be entirely inseparable concepts
which is why we now appear to have a
fully fledged toshi fushiguru just sort
of running about doing his thing
which is terrifying and also jujitsukai
sen just continues to spit in the face
of my feelings regarding resurrections
and media
usually i would be cringing like
uncontrollably at the very thought of
bringing toji back into the story after
dying
however akutami is doing this very
effectively by tying it to this whole
body versus soul discussion and not just
like a lame fan service you resurrection
because either the character was popular
or the author didn't actually have the
balls to kill them which are the two
main reasons why narrative resurrections
tend to occur so toji has a very
interesting x-factor presence right now
and that's where i ended this part of
the shibuya rock fushiguro and company
were about to escape from here the
cthulhu dude i think his name is dagon
anyway it doesn't matter in
pop stoji so i'm very much looking
forward to seeing how that's handled
with the hollow father-son dynamic but
many many other conflicts are occurring
several of which feature el plucky young
yuji who is very much back into serious
business mode
after hearing that mahito was
responsible for this he immediately
switched back
up into that june pay trauma with a
straight up look of
kill kill kill so it feels like a setup
for some pretty big ug drama happening
here in the future although the most
interesting conflict thus far is
definitely his fight with chosen which
kind of blew my mind because we had a
surprise repeat of the toto situation
you know the whole it was at this very
moment that the memory was born inside
chosen's brain of a past event
that never happened and that was wild i
legitimately thought that that was just
a stupid but
fun toyota joke an event that was
completely the result of his
very odd brain thing which is still odd
even though this isn't his doing but now
that it's happened again and under such
a serious context as well this is
clearly some sort of like
innate eug ability yeah because we know
it's not sukun is doing because even he
was surprised by what happened
i think so i met a bit of a loss here
because that was definitely unexpected
although it does serve as a nice
contrast to what mojito does i suppose
you know he manipulates the body
via the soul whilst yuji is somehow
capable of manipulating the mind i don't
know maybe even by
the soul because does manipulating the
mind manipulate the soul
i don't know neither toto nor choso have
been physically changed but maybe this
is the mechanism by which yuji could
effectively face off against mahito
without letting sukuna take full control
and i'm just sort of assuming that chozo
is now going to become an ally of yuji
not entirely sure but his brotherly
bonds are so powerful that i don't think
he'll be able to ignore this
and having briefly brought up tsukuna
mahito seems to be playing a very
dangerous game here at the outset of the
series we were told that for this very
plan to succeed the one the thing that
we're doing right here and now
we needed two things one the ceiling of
satoru gojo
and two the cooperation of sukuna so
mahito is abandoning a whole half of
this plan here which i find pretty
surprising considering he's experienced
firsthand just how powerful sukuna is
but that change of heart seems to be a
potential key to salvation here you know
not being saved by humanity's most
powerful warrior of goodness
and stuff in gojo but finding victory
through the depths of
sukuna meanwhile meimei also has quite a
bit of focus thus far alongside her
little brother thing
comedically they were pretty amazing but
what really made me sit up and pay
attention was their fight against the
special great disease curse which had
this this sort of complicated domain
thing going on a series of three
conditions trapping someone in the
coffin bearing it with the gravestone
and then a three second countdown
i find that sort of ability really
really fun to read because it adds this
great extra layer to combat i get bored
very easily when it's just
about you know hit the people with the
powerful attacks i prefer more strategic
battles which engage the mind as well
which is exactly what this is
as well as pretty much every other fight
in the arc thus far and another fun
example of a tactical struggle would be
against
old moustache guy i don't know his name
i don't remember if it was mentioned but
he had the inverse curse technique where
strong becomes weak and weak becomes
strong so yuji and fushiguru had to come
up with a unique strategy to land the
weakest possible attack on the old guy
but one that would still register on his
scale and that really is another step
towards jujitsu kaisen becoming a bit
more like jojo's bizarre adventure where
every battle presents a completely
unique problem to be solved which is not
at all a bad thing and since it doesn't
look like he'll be too relevant going
forward let's also mention ino right now
i legit
thought this guy was just going to be
some sort of throwaway character that we
may or may not see ever again but it is
nice to know that he's not as shallow as
just wanting a title for the sake of it
and actually has a somewhat deep
connection to naomi seeking his approval
and such pretty cool curse technique as
well he just got very
very unlucky with his opponent so as a
right now shibuya is simply insane it's
very difficult to predict how the story
is going to end but i am very much
looking forward to seeing more from
characters who were less featured thus
far like kinamaki who popped up towards
the end of where i stopped as well as
panda always panda more panda
now there's a wealth of great character
interactions left to explore as well as
an entire series climax to play out so
i'm going to go and do that now because
that pretty much does it for this half
of jujutsukai sen shibuya incident
arc and what do you guys think please
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more jujutsu
sorcery then please do check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe regular jujutsu
kaiser morbidity administered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time